So far, we've been dealing with this
funny virtual time or logical time. But there
are many real-world scenarios where this logical time
may not be good enough. And in such
situations, this logical clock may not be sufficient. I'll give you an example.
Let's say that I owe you some money. And I tell you by calling you on the phone,
that I'm going to credit my account in my local
branch at 5 p.m. I'm telling you on the phone
that I'm going to credit my account at 5 p.m.,
and so any time after 5 p.m., you can withdraw
money from my bank, and we'll be square. Now
you're a nice guy, so you want to give me
some leeway. So you tell your branch that, you
know, at 8:00 PM, go ahead and debit from Kishore's
account the money that he owes me. So your branch is
going to basically do a debit call to the central bank
server asking for the money that is owed by Kishore to
be transferred to your account, so that's what is going to happen. And
so you schedule that at 8 p.m. You've given me enough
time to make sure that you have indicated to your bank,
you have enough money, so that my debit transaction can go
through. And you would think it should go through, right? But it
turns out, that your branch's local time is
far ahead of real time. Well, it thought it
was 8 p.m., it was not quite 8 p.m.,
yet. Because it's way ahead of real time. And
so I am exactly at 5 p.m., keeping my
word, exactly at 5 p.m., my branch happens to
be good with the time. It's, it's in sync with the real time. And so at 5 p.m.,
I've done the credit of the amount that I
owe you to my central bank server. But unfortunately,
the central bank server, in real time, it got
your message much earlier than the time at which I
sent my message. It's not looking at any logical
time. It is looking at real time, saying, well, there's
a debit transaction coming in. Is there money in
the bank for paying those debit transactions? No, it isn't.
So your request is declined. And this is coming about because of the fact that
in real world scenarios, logical clocks are not
good enough. And in particular, what caused this
problem is the fact that your notion,
your branch's notion, of real time is completely
at odds with real time. And the reason
that can happen is because the computer at
your local bank may have a clock that is drifting
with respect to real time. So is drifting meaning that it
is not keeping up with the real time. It's either
going faster than real time or it is going slower than
the real time. It so happens that my, my branch's
time is is perfectly in sync with the real time, but
that doesn't help me. And this is a real world
scenario that you have to worry about. And such anomalies occur
due to two things. One is individual clock drifts. Because if you think about a
clock, clock is a piece of circuitry, and
you expect that for every second of real
time, your clock is also going to click a tick by the same one second. But
if it doesn't, your idea of real time
is going to slowly drift. That is called individual
clock drift. And also, there is a possibility that
there could be a relative drift between the clocks
that are there in different processors. This clock can
be ticking at a particular rate, and this clock
would be ticking at a different rate from my
clock, and that can cause a second source of
discrepancy. And these anomalies are nasty things that we
have to avoid in order to make sure that in
real world we can have some guarantees about what goes on.